[Music]
and welcome to the council meeting of
trances may 20 19 tells us and the ex
counselors and the rest are my first
religious and mystical agents where are
the toilets our situation outside the
meeting room or outside the meeting the
fire alarm chirp sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
science and meet the Ipswich Town
Football Club training which do not be
enter the building until your talent
into safe to do so
pace which offer a mobile phones will
return them outside the repair cost and
life to the Internet and will being
repeated the whole nation will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
sent items if you make a representation
to the machine will be gained by the
counselor to have consented to be filled
by entering this room we are consenting
to being filmed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
besides just village it's about
responsibilities I think that's
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
important
she has been an outstanding counsellor
for festival food she is a balanced and
fair candidate she's worked on committee
out and planning and she's been a member
of scrutiny and she wrote about a
candidate for chair as a good permanent
ambassador for the council thank you
[Music]
[Music]
no Mike Norris as a long-term Chancellor
of this county there's this council who
held a whole number of roles over an
extended period and he represents on the
experienced individual who I'm sure
would fulfill the roles of chair yes no
I think that must be 12 years now and
I'm very happy to be second in for this
position I've served on the committee
under his chairmanship and I know that
he will do this job in the most
excellent way and impartially as well
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry so what are some favor of
Chancellor noise patient I'm sure you
probably guessed what the situation is
no surprises there [ __ ]
so it's left as my last duty of the
society to make the casting vote as
chairman and I have the casting vote and
I cast a vote goes to counselor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you I'm councillor Flatman and the
councillor move for my kind words of my
election to the chair before we continue
with the meeting I'd like to enjoy me
invite you all to join me in thanking
deck for his years of service to
mid-south up here is done an excellent
job is undertaken as the district for
the future residents and organizations
of minutes to speak to the assembled
company here one or two 16 years ago
seemed ages away but I do wanna pay
tribute today because he was our deputy
leader the Treasury which is a pretty
thankless task of course but in all
sincerity he's been wonderful for mid
Suffolk the council oversee his own
particular war but for Suffolk as a
whole cause he never suffer fools gladly
you say that people don't just get it
and I remember one time sincerity
[Music]
dedication and integrity is quite a rare
thing these days and I think we're very
very grateful Derek for me personally
you certainly tried to keep me under
control
nor is an excellent sounding board and I
think any of us aware is needed a unity
trusted friend and really trusted friend
to me is someone who can tell me the
things that sometimes are not terribly
Pleasant and keep you guide in the right
way because you know they do absolutely
the right reasons so we should say not
to see you in the meantime juice doesn't
come from South Africa it actually comes
from using but we want to give this to
you as a token of our appreciation for
all that you've done for mid Suffolk and
over the last 16 years and wish you all
the very very best and I'm sure we'll
keep in touch and if you're kind enough
we'll come back and hit this
[Music]
[Music]
I sure
[Applause]
man Smitty Ben thanks very much chair
and we have often had disappointments in
fact I would be starting to remember an
agreement have been able to disagree and
that's how it is we have four different
opinions and then we move on and I think
that's the whole point is just being
extremely fair about how you agree or
disagree with each other in terms of
council business and I think Derek has
worked extremely hard and firm in
Suffolk over his tenure here and Matt
melius to be congratulated because
there's many people who just haven't
turned up to meetings and and haven't
done what they should be doing in
committees and so on but but Derek is
always always done that him always 100%
intimate Suffolk Thank You Terry
Thank You Jay
[Music]
when I first is approached by a certain
member to stand for the 2015 elections I
didn't really understand what all this
was all about and I thought right I'm
gonna ring up the leader and see what
he's got to say for himself and I rang
up Derrick and said can I come and have
a chat with you so I know what's going
on he said yeah cool she can come in
tell him so I came in then we had a
brief chat he's scheduled I found me his
commitment and his dedication is know to
be honest it's second to none in this
chamber and I've been really privileged
to work with Derrick over the last four
years what you see is what you get he
says exactly what he's thinking you know
exactly where you stand and it's been a
fantastic privilege to work with him for
the last voyage thank you thank you I'm
now going to read out the declaration of
acceptance of a person so I can move in
you're hugging them having been duly
elected to the office of chairman of Mid
South District Council declared about
take that office upon myself well Julian
faithfully perform the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability and to take that in performing
the functions of Chairman I should
observe a perfect local code of conduct
as a doctor David counsel
item number two and that agenda is the
election of vice chairman of the council
may have nominations for both Changmin
chairman Thank You chair I would like to
nominate Barry Humphries I was
privileged to be asked by coastal
Humphries four years ago when I stood in
2015 if I be able to stand for both
stone market town council and mid
Suffolk District Council and I was
delighted to take up both of those
efforts I also like to be elected very
very closely over the last four years
he's very very fair his dealings and
committees etc and therefore I recommend
him for vice chairman thank you thank
you I would to second the proposal of
Barry Humphries council belly Barry
Humphries and he's an extremely fair and
articulate counsellor and he will make
an excellent job of being vice chair
thank you thank you I want to propose
for election to nice challenge in a very
able and vigorous candidate in this role
having probably told most of the
children of Mid South how to do out it
certainly all of my children and so ii
ii ii map
Tesla baby-faced having been duly
elected to the office of vice chairman
admit super District Council declared
outside the office upon myself with
Julie and faithfully fulfill the duties
of its apparent to the best of my
judgment and ability and it taking the
performing the functions of
vice-chairman I shall observe the superb
local code of conduct was adopted by the
council
but what's Thank You Adam I propose it
my certainly and put a faith in this
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'm moving on to agenda item number
three apologies for absence very limited
item number four declaration of interest
by councillors and any declarations also
member fails to confirm the minutes of
the meeting hope and the 18th of March
that will suit only and there any issues
with accuracy today I propose a please
madam chairman please
all those in favor thank you that's
carried
item number six the Chairman's
announcements were fade to paper MC /
19/2 to be noted so moving uncertain
understanding their lecture the leak at
the leader of the council most
nominations for the leader of the
council Thank You counselor bathroom I
would like to propose counselor Susan
Mary she is the conservative an
independent group has a great confidence
in Susie as a new leader
she's always indicated she wishes to
lead the council as attended leadership
courses and been a valued member on the
cabinet the group with old and new
members have gelled quickly Susan is
professional approachable and can
assimilate new situations swiftly and
this group feels that the council will
be in safe hands
Thank You District Council about six
years ago in her past his chairman of
the debonair Leisure Centre I was
impressed from day one and her
determination to get things done for her
residents and I'm sure she'll carry that
forward to the wider mid-south for
Gary's as leader she has a karma
she has an ability to continue that
approach as we go forward around the
table can certain second counselor
maximize the time to speak we're going
to go straight into after the elections
know when a party has a majority we have
a such we believe that we should be
having a leader that can actually ensure
a cabinet where we have put failure
holders from all parties the split
between the voters was 50/50 the
electorate would therefore expect us to
put together a cabinet that is that
represents that so has 50% members from
the Liberal Democrats and the Green
Party who are working together and 50%
members from the independents and the
Conservatives that are working together
and they should all be full members I'm
a portfolio holders I'm not long as well
you don't have a portfolio holder so
cabinet members have moved portfolio and
it really is extremely important to
reflect what
happened in the election and I strongly
believe that if farmers to be elected as
leader I will be able to carry that
through and ensure that we all get
together around a table and wits and if
it's equal we'll need to be doing this
for the good of the council it's not
about me they're with us on this side
with you on that side we should be
working together has happened in the
election on the 2nd of May thank you
very much such a split Council with
power and decision making it's not the
most efficient way to run a council I
think this is a very sad case that to
work together collaboratively we wish to
do so we can go straight to the boat so
all those in favor of canceling rolling
and all those in favor of em can smell
em eben
could I be told I wasn't there to speak
during that despite putting my hand up
eliminations there's no debate it's only
the proposer and the second Oh who had
the opportunity I'm still tired so when
she's my post and vote for counsel
enrolling leaving on to agenda item
number 8 informative announcements madam
chairman it is a great and humbling
honor to be elected leader of not-self
district council I do so at a time of
significant change but also following a
time of great progress and achievement
but we members and officers can be proud
of in the last four years this
conservative administration has worked
hard to make mid Suffolk a better place
for everyone we've invested millions in
our community facilities built more
affordable homes started building
council homes again the first in the
generation and kept our streets clean
tidy and safe report empty properties
back into use tackle homelessness and
funded community groups who do some
truly amazing work we have regenerated
key errors in our district so that we
can only proud to call with self of our
home I welcome mid Suffolk being voted
one of the top places to live in the UK
we accept that there is much more to do
but this cannot possibly be done without
a strong thriving private sector this is
where the money comes from and we will
do what we can to encourage business
growth in a sustainable manner for the
benefit of everyone the elections
earlier this month were clearly very
difficult for us
I believe our record is strong but it
was not strong enough to understand the
national swing that saw so many
conservative counts
good counselors that worked hard for
their communities lose their seats and I
would like to put on record my thanks
for their achievements nevertheless
we'll have to deal with the consequences
we have to find a way that we feel in
our hearts that we can best serve the
people in need suffered since the
elections I've met the leaders of
leather groups on several occasions
where I'm grateful to them for entering
into these talks which have been
productive helpful and focused on how we
may might be able to work together I'm
confident the council Oh burn counselor
field and I can and will have a
productive working relationship
respecting each other's views whilst not
necessarily agreeing with each other I
truly believe that leadership is a
behavior not a role and I believe our
skills and our passion to do the right
thing are up to this challenge there are
many things we agree on not least how
important it is that we make mid Suffolk
a better place to live work and visit
there are however some significant
issues where we dramatically our
discussions have focused on those areas
of disagreement in particular the future
role of Cisco and the location of our
headquarters for our group the financial
case for 670,000
in the first year alone hello that's
equivalent to eleven percent on the
council tax this is money we would
otherwise not have access to the service
is likely to suffer as a result
through the move to endeavor house this
public sector hub we alongside Weber
expect to save almost 6 million pounds
in property costs over the next decade
this again is money that can then be
reinvested in the services our residents
value the most in doing so were now in
the process of transforming our old
offices in leader market into
much-needed local housing and retail
space the comrade survey carried out
last summer showed that the most
important things to our residents was
keeping council tax low whilst
continuing to deliver local services it
was not moving staff that residents
don't need to interact with back to lead
and market for staff that our residents
do need to interact with they are out
and about in our district and if
required we have our office in stone
market it's clear from the election
literature that the opposition wish to
undo this work their political asks are
not acceptable to us and sadly we have
not been able to find consensus we
believe that what they are proposing
will be damaging to this councils
financial future putting increased
pressure on services we believe that
what they are proposing would waste
valuable taxpayers money we therefore
cannot in all good conscience format an
administration with the green and
Liberal Democrats our group has
therefore joined with councillor
Brewster to form an administration
together we will leave this council to
any national and local uncertainty that
lies ahead I recognize that it will be
difficult but sometimes that's just the
way it is let's get on with it I do
however extend the hand of cooperation
as has been the way in mid suffered for
many years the offer of a seat in our
cabinet remains open should councillor
Byrne and councillor field wish to take
it I'm visit an exciting program of
collaboration and cooperation where we
will share resources across the public
sector in the coming weeks and months
our administration will set out its
priorities for the next four years we
welcome a lively debate on this
and as in the previous four years we
will be open transparent and inclusive
today however I wish to make two of my
personal priorities crystal-clear the
first is the people we are here to serve
when I became cabinet member for
organizational delivery with
responsibility for customer services I
learned very quickly how important it
was to put our residents and service
users at the heart of everything you do
I also learned how much we already do
delivered by dedicated and hardworking
staff every single day I wish to pay
tribute to them and hope you will all
join me in expressing our gratitude to
them I would also like to thank all of
our Ward counselors who work tirelessly
for their towns and parishes I've been
accustomed myself customer myself
frustrated at how difficult it is to
find the information I need I find it a
constant source of exasperation but the
best way to find information on our
website is to use an external search
engine and just because we are often the
only organization that offers a
particular service it doesn't mean we
can act as if that is the case we must
treat every interaction with our
residents and service users as if they
could choose a different service
provider we must treat them as customers
it's a way of thinking and working that
I want to see expanded in this council
as leader I will make this a fundamental
pillar of our work in mid Suffolk
whether that's involving people in
decision-making improving access to
services or designing services around
their needs and our communication with
the public needs to be far better and
proactive we are here to improve their
lives and to do that we need to start
with and remain focused on them I'm also
making a priority of avoiding our joint
Local Plan this is arguably one of the
most important pieces of work that we
have before us it is the most important
it is vital that we ensure that housing
and building development in our district
is where and how
we want it to be it's as important it is
important to our residents that we get
it right our administration will
therefore ensure that the council
continues to work at pace bringing
proposals for public consultation
forward to members this summer I'm still
tweaking my cabinet appointments and I
will have this to the monitoring officer
tomorrow however I would like to make
one further announcement which is that
my deputy leader will be counselor
rooster I cannot think of a safer pair
of hands to back me up in these
difficult times so my message to members
staff and residents is a very simple one
mid Suffolk District Council is focused
on its residents and service users they
are at the heart of what we do how we do
it and why we are here you must always
remember this fact and make sure their
needs are visible in the decisions we
make and the actions we take we will put
them first thank you thank you
there's some questions that people want
to ask but remember this is not an item
for debate council even would you like
to start
um thank you very much chair and I
welcome councillor Morley as a leader of
the council in the run-up to this
meeting it was me that asked for
meetings with the Liberal Democrats and
the Conservatives in order that we could
develop a consensus across across the
chamber and that is the type of person I
am looking for consensus so I was the
one who wanted to have those meetings to
see what we could find a way through and
I'd love to have had a seat on cabinet
provided it's on an equal basis with a
portfolio as the as the vote bomb showed
50 percent of the electorate 50 percent
voted for the people on this side of the
chamber and on the basis that Japan have
a question
I will bring to a question thank you
they vote 50% of the electorate voted
for us on the basis that they did not
like the way we were progressing with
Cisco and they did not want to see
investment in property outside of mr.
Cook
so what I would like to see is much more
investment in housing in this area and
actually hoped what we're doing with
Cisco and actually bring the money back
here to to develop it in housing so I'd
like to ask if that could be one of the
first priorities of this council thank
you answer Lawton thank you very much
respond to that discussion around
discussions around Cisco are not up for
debate
we've made the decision that that is the
way we are progressing things and we
will continue it is not a question of
either or we can continue to invest in
Cisco and we can also invest in housing
they're not mutually exclusive and
Slaton thank you I'm terrified that I'm
going to go back in way back in history
of mid Suffolk District Council probably
only me and councillor staff witnessed
the situation when I was in your
position as leader of a council that was
relying on the Chairman's casting vote
city I have to say you're taking a huge
risk and I don't envy you having to deal
with the council under those
circumstances I was flat faced actually
with a opposition motion of
no-confidence is a question I'm getting
to the question to a motion of
no-confidence the council then have to
be disbanded for the time being to
reconsider not disbanded but yes
suspended and then to go back into a
room so what I'm saying to you because I
am disappointed that we haven't been
able to come to some relief and
agreement between the group leaders to
have a rainbow alliance of a cabinet
will you can reconsider if you feel that
it would be to your advantage to
actually go back and have a discussion
again with the two group leaders from
the other groups my door is always open
for discussion
Thank You counselor field thank you
please to hear the doors always open
thank you I know position obviously the
question really just revolves around
Cisco which was the big issue as far as
we were concerned really the question is
really do you totally believe that
you've adequately assessed the risk that
is present in the commercial market
particularly the retail market at the
moment now we can see continuous
collapsing of retail operations even
notice that wagamama I think is has some
problem certain significant problems at
the moment so it seems to suggest that
although you're achieving a yield from
your investment needs a very substantial
risk that you could lose sure thank you
the Brewster
think about of Chairman yes we are
satisfied that that risk is properly
managed we have the some of the really
top experts in that field to look at the
investment we are advised throughout
legally due diligence and so on and we
regularly look at the risk factor as do
civico the board of Cisco so I am
absolutely happy that that risk is being
managed and obviously as I said the
other day the any further investment to
retail at this time is is paused so the
risk is less there
councillor stringer to your question
Thank You chair and and congratulate
councillor Morley on her new role one of
the great lessons I've had in the last
few weeks bumping into numerous people
on doorsteps one of the overwhelming
issues that popped up was a question
from them saying why do you look keep
bickering and don't just work together
and actually I think it's an awful lot
now and of course 41% of those people
voted for the conservative program and
51% of the vote 61 60 59 % Oh 59 percent
voted for alternative programs and then
to suggest that by an outgoing
Chairman's constant vote that then 100%
of the program goes on that side of the
room here's a little bit of a difficult
sell I think to a lot of people so my
overwhelming concern is though that
we're gonna have a really boring four
years really boring sorry have you got
another appointment we we yeah it could
be really boring in terms of just you
know lots of Chairman's casting votes et
cetera et cetera I get that but and I
think there could be a road route that
we could actually work together but
there are my primary concern is have you
actually thought about the staff in this
decision because it is the staff that
would do a lot of their work on
a lot of those work programs that could
well be dashed if somebody doesn't turn
up or somebody's late for a meeting and
it's just that I want to make sure that
you have double thought about thank you
morning counselor Hicks maybe I'll have
a question counselor Morley 14,000 289
people voted conservative and 11,000 944
voted green so I think actually that
gives a clear reflection to give counts
of Morley confidence in moving forward
with her leadership my question really
is is why do you think counselor field
and cancer ebin did not want to take up
your offer joining your cabinet do you
have an answer counselor morning I think
as I've already said the areas where we
couldn't agree were around Cisco and
moving our headquarters back to me to
market those are fundamental decisions
that were in the opposition's manifesto
and we cannot renege on the decisions
that we've already made thank you
because actually I wrote the Green Party
manifesto for this election and it
category did not say that the
headquarters is going back to need a
market it said we have used the depo
site to build an office using the
underspend some of the underspend from
last year for frontline stuff to be
there so I just want to carry for that
thank you
moving on so the next item on the agenda
which is up item number nine a
designation of committees and joint
committees to appoint the following
committees and joint committees minced
up at overview and scrutiny committee
development control committee a
Development Control Committee be
planning the Farris committee mid
Suffolk Licensing and regulatory
committee joint order and standards
committee and the joint appointments
committee could I have a proposer to a
point all the committee's listed on the
agenda
thank you cancel it Armbruster thank you
I'm chairman yes I'm very happy to
propose these committees on blog I'm
sure thank you out great 30 light second
in the proposal I said all those in
favor for appointing the committee's
that's carried thank you
moving on to item 10 the political
balance and composition of the
committee's I will fade to paper MC / 19
/ 3 and appendices a and B in the table
pack I'd like to invite Jan Robinson to
introduce the paper and Thank You chair
just to say that the purposes of this
report is to comply with the provisions
of the local government and Housing Act
which require a local authority to
review the allocations of seats to
political groups at every annual meeting
of the council or as soon as practicable
laughter for meetings I just want to
point out one change to the
recommendation
and it should read that committee
members be appointed as set out in
Appendix B to this report and that the
name substitute part be removed thank
you the second man sir thank you my
chair I just like to point out that the
fact that both councillor Richardson and
councillor Turner are on Planning
development Control Committee a may
cause a bit of an issue because they
both represent the 1st and Ward and
should there be a Thurston application
which is said to development control
committee a they we both have to move
across the floor and there will only be
six members actually making that
decision so I'm not sure that that is
the best composition for development
control committee a Thank You councillor
Mansell
the committee's
may have a nomination for the chair
overview and scrutiny committee
counselor Morley
Thank You chair I would like to propose
Keith well in this chair you may have a
second day Thank You counsel
nominations all those in favor
thank you that may have a nomination for
the vice chair both viewing scrutiny
committee thank you Kevin Thank You
chair I would like to probe proposed
council Ikeda scarf is West have a
seconder thank you
Nations
may I have a nomination for the chair of
development Control Committee a can the
councillor max thank you Jeff
I'd like to propose councillor Sarah
mental chair of the committee thank you
is there a seconder
thank you Kevin I would like to propose
councillor Hicks thank you
it's a be a seconder
favor of counselor Hicks so that's the
jaw so I'm gonna use my casting vote for
counselor Hicks
I have nominations for Vice Chair
development control committee a
counselor head in this chair thank you
thank you
I'm sorry any other nominations vote all
those in favor of counselor adding him
um so many have nominations for the
chair development control be pleased
councillor Morley thank you do I have a
seconder do you have a seconder Thank
You councillor Flatman is there any
other nominations
council lady Bern I'd like to nominate
councillor Sarah Mansell and I really do
ask that we can actually share a morning
it shouldn't be political
so council say a man that has got
fantastic experience on planning I want
it be great if we could have Sarah as a
chair of a planning committee that
really apparently we can't take that
because she's not on that committee um
thank you - excuse me chair if I may
point forward - I did ask that
beforehand and was advised that that
would be okay because we because we
could fit through that I asked the
Democratic services that could happen in
terms of positions across planning and
chair just to clarify so if you wanted
to do that you would need to remove
counts of manslaughter committee a and
move her to counts development B is that
what you'd like to do if she were to be
successful as on this I've got your
first got to do it first okay well I
withdraw that seems that we it wouldn't
be carried anyway because I suspect that
chair would use a casting vote once
again so with with the head with a heavy
heart I won't draw it
so all those in favor of councillor
Guthrie for the chair of development
control bean
and votes against
nominations for Vice Chair development
controlled be councillor morally I would
like to propose councillor Barry
Humphries have a seconder councillor
Miller is there any other nominations we
get we'll go straight to vote all those
in favor of counselor um that Humphries
that's carried may have nominations for
the chair of Licensing and regulatory
committee counsel and Morley do you have
a seconder not sure I'd like to second
uh proposal Thank You councillor
Humphries it's a and any other
nominations councillor Willem Thank You
chair I would like to propose councillor
Andrew stringer thank you
do you have a seconder councillor man
I'm happy to second that thank you so
all those in favor of council of
gatherings favor of um councillors
ringer all right so um I'll release my
vote for I'm councillor gathering
may have no nations for vice-chair of
life sneak licensing and regulatory
committee councillor Morley do I have a
seconder Thank You jobs and happy to do
something thank you any other
nominations cancel Philips I'd like to
propose councillor stringer thank you
all those in favor of date mother
well this in favor of councillor
stringer that's a draw
thank you so I'll exercise my casting
vote for a councillor Miller may have
nominations for the chair joint order
and standards committee Houston morally
I would like to propose councillor
moolah do you have a seconder thank you
I'm happy to second thank you any other
nominations cancer fix like to propose
cancer Mike Norris
thank you very much I'd like to second
counter mic noise it's in favor of I'm
council herb Miller
I see all those in favor of councillor
Norris at least my casting vote for
councillor Miller
as this is a joint committee where the
chair alternates between the two
districts there's no need to appoint a
vice chair on this occasion I have a
nominations for the chair joint
appointments committee Thank You Council
is there any other nominations so we'll
go straight to vote all those in favor
counselor morning that's carried may
have nominations for the vice chair
during appointments committee counselor
Morley I would like to propose
councillor Brewster thank you do you
have a seconder I'm happy to second
councillor Brewster thank you patient so
I go straight to the boat all those in
favor councillor Brewster those against
that's Carrie
right so moving on to item 12
that's appointments to outside bodies I
refer you to pay for MC / 19 / 4 and
Appendix A in the table pack I'd like to
invite the leader to introduce paper MC
/ 19 step 4 and move the recommendation
in the report
let the counselors be appointed to
outside bodies as detailed in Appendix A
and I propose the recommendation okay I
have a seconder please
thanks councillor Brewster I'm happy to
second that proposal automatic to speak
hmm I did want to make sure we are
dealing with Appendix A what um I would
like to propose that the leader of the
main opposition group is given a place
on the East of England assembly the East
of England Local Government Association
and the Local Government Association
Assembly
thank you madam chair counselors can
propose amendments however in some cases
the person who is required to be a
member of those bodies is specified so
in the case of the East of England
assembly of leaders it is the leader of
the council who must be the council's
appointed representative the East of
England Local Government Association
could be an alternative nomination and
apologies councillors and I didn't catch
the third outside body that you referred
to the LGA and assembly say I would
expect a leader to be giving a player to
be given a place that those three but I
really think that with the political
balance of this council it would really
be appropriate for the leader of the
main opposition to actually be allowed
to attend those meetings I think if I'm
right that would be at the gift of the
council madam chair and I believe we
only have one place on each of those
bodies however we can take that away and
see if it's possible for us to have more
than one places and then bring that back
to the council yeah I think you're right
they probably only have a voting place I
think what we're asking for that there
is representation from the rest of the
country get away councillor Ellen would
you accept me I think you chair that
there seem to be a bit of confusing over
drainage
we've got East Suffolk drainage board
three representatives appear to have
already been elected through to 2020 and
I'm one of those and I believe
councillor Marchant was also one of
those and we've got the east up of
internal drainage board which i think is
exactly the same thing and we've got
three people on that board as well and
those three people James Caston I think
some counselor caster confirm they are
one in the same I believe they are the
same them meeting and thank you very
much chair I think it's quite
disappointing that we've heard from the
leader about working together yet when I
look through this list I can't really
see anybody on this side of the room
apart from Keith on the list and yes
these are positions that the the council
sends representatives to so it should be
representative hopefully of the whole
council and they're not ones that are
like directing the work of mid Suffolk
they are ones where members have to go
along to report back you know make sure
warned they actually attend these
meetings and then report back to full
council so the rest of Council know you
know what's been said and what's going
on so I think it would have been really
good to have actually mixed these up and
there wouldn't have been I can't see
there would have been a problem with
that secondly secondly I think that
these probably should be reviewed do we
need to be on all of these and I've been
helped we looked at all of these and I
think it might be a good idea actually
to put this into scrutiny because also
then that there might be other ones that
we should be on you know are there other
areas that actually affect a lot of our
people's lives and the qualities of
their lives and we as counselors
somebody should be on that particular
the board we've had a debate on and off
about CA B in the past which I don't
think I'm just put this list before just
before the meeting I don't think it's on
the list
anymore but it used to be on the list
came off when on came off again that's
Lieber and cetera so so the point is
that you know there are others that
other members might suggest to be on and
therefore should we look at it you know
but I would like to have a feeling from
this council meeting whether that's
possible thank you very much and chair
just Ryu description he did have it on
its work program last year we've taken
an initial look and done some work on it
but it is coming back to review now that
we're going to have a year once we've
had a year under the belt to see what
work is being done and we will also be
looking at other organizations to see
whether it's appropriate whether we
should be appointing to those bodies as
well thank you we need to decide which
of these organizations we want to be
able to influence and which it would be
far better for them just to give us a
report I'm happy to look at that thanks
counselor Richardson thank you madam
chair could I just propose one small
amendment to the pending a as I'm not
able to sit on both the health and
well-being board and the health scrutiny
committee could I instead propose that
counselor flatten that is a point of
health and well-being board instead yes
thank you gotta be noted
so if there's no other speakers we'll
get the boat at that amendment
to the proposer and ii accept the
amendment of councillor Richardson's yes
chair happy to accept that
everything counselor Busa yes you do
chair if I can just confirm so the
amendment that's been agreed by the
proposer and ii do is that jude
councillor julie Flatman becomes the
main post holder on that outside body
which then means that the council needs
to put forward a substitute or
alternatively you can do that later by
me thank you they'll put that to the
vote with that amendment all those in
favor that's Carrie so now moving on to
item number 13 the appointment of
councillors to the shared revenues
partnership committee in accordance with
the joint Arrangements established with
Bebo District Council and Ipswich
Borough Council Council is asked to
appoint two cabinet members and two
substitutes to serve on the committee
for the current municipal year as the
cabinet members are yet to be announced
this item will be deferred into the next
council meeting item number 14
appointments the Suffolk joint standards
board in accordance with the joint
Arrangements established at Weber
District Council and Suffolk County
Council Council is asked to 0.3
councillors to serve on the board for
the current municipal year the political
balance rules do not apply to mid suffix
appointees who cannot be chairman of the
council and members of the cabinet
nominations have been tabled could I
have a proposer thank you come on show
us I'd like to propose acceptance of
that soma do I have a seconder thank you
I'm happy to second that thank you so
I'll go to the back so all those in
favor
that's carried
so item number 15 appointment to join
gypsy and travelers steering group
Council is asked to point four
counselors to the joint gypsy and
traveling stick travelers steering group
I believe some combinations have been
tabled are there any further nominations
councillor Morley just proposed thank
you could I have a seconder
thank you never gets the boat all those
in favor that's carried so lastly item
number 16 appointments to council
working groups I refer you to the paper
tabled over any more appointments so
could I have a proposal for that thank
you thank you could I have a seconder
I'd like to second it thank you madam
chairman thank you so I'll put that
sorry Thank You chair I know you're
stealing on but could I just ask with
the community governance review could I
just ask the monitoring officer to
explain because I understand that that
might be delayed for 12 months we
haven't put someone forward on the on
the basis that it is likely to be
delayed 12 months and therefore one of
our representatives that's on another
another group might then go on to that
one in 12 months time as it were so
hence there's no nominee from us but I
just wondered if the monitor officers
can just explain for the benefit of
everyone what might be happening with
that thank you thank you madam chair the
community governance review group is to
look at a request from batis for parish
council the terms of reference for which
has already been agreed by this council
however we now know that there will be a
review of county divisions within the
near future which is likely to require
us to do a wholesale
view of all the parishes in the district
and therefore it would seem sensible to
delay this review and do everything
together as one however those times of
reference will need to be altered by the
council um so we'll go to the boat for
that so all those in favor I'm sorry yep
sure Thank You chair so if I could just
add Sarah Mansell to that list so she'll
have finished don't want to start the
next one thank you I'm so let's go to
the boat all those in favor that's
Carrie sorry um um it's cancer please
just on that term community governments
with you I have another parish I'm aware
of that's seeking to transition from a
parish meeting into a parish council
always highly likely to be doing that
would that mean that too is delayed for
a year
madam chair the the regulations around
the triggering of a community
governments review are quite complex so
I'll speak to count Smithfield outside
of the meeting okay so the date that the
next meeting is Thursday the 27th of
June at 5:30 p.m. and I declare this
meeting closed
I'm sorry gang downstairs now for the do